right never watch trailers and then do
videos on those trailers for the movie
and then at a point you're like I'm done
doing videos on those trailers I'll just
watch the movie because it's Ninja
Turtles and it doesn't look good anyway
and then you see a trailer and you're
like I should probably talk about that
though no I'm talking about you the
whole time yeah that's this so any
trailer for Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
came out and there's information in
there that made me go wait a minute wait
a minute so this trailer starts out you
see the Ninja Turtles doing their
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles thing and
that looks cool everyone's kicking ass
they're all cowabunga there's a
Throwdown in the subway which one of
them throws a guy through his subway
card you're like he's dead no one lives
through that pretty sure that guy
died when April finds the turtles and
she takes a picture they're like oh she
took a picture of us so they're like
intimidating her that I don't speak of
this to anyone one of them's like oh
he's doing his Batman voice I was like
wait does that mean the Dark Knight
exists in this world but the interesting
thing is when William Fichtner the guy
who was playing shredder is talking to
this seedy shadowy bald messed up face
looking guy that you don't know he
hasn't messed up face because he's in
the shadows he looks like he hasn't
messed up face he just looks menacing
he's just looking at him like that
Victor's like we're gonna take your
armor to the next level and then it
shows mecha transformers shredder armor
wait wait does that mean that guy that
you've said has been shredder all this
time is not actually shredder this other
guy is actually shredder in which case
why the secrecy why not just be like
yeah that guy's shredder that guy's not
now you don't have to hate the movie
youtubers and bloggers there's a part of
me other thing to people like me
ruin it for everyone but were they like
okay we're gonna say that this guy's
shredder but he's not actually shredder
is actually gonna be this other guy it's
gonna be a really cool reveal then
everyone was like this movie that's not
shredder in the studio and the director
and the producers were all like you know
what screw it shorten the trailer we had
a plan they didn't have faith and now
it's ruined for everyone good job Jeremy
oh well it's still time you should have
shown us our shredder I understand in
some movies you want secrets and you
want reveals and that's really neat when
you have iconic characters like the main
villain of the iconic Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle franchise you can't really
do that just say hey here is shredder
out the gate and then there's this guy
in which case who does he play now
theory time based on the information a
possibility that that guy is shredder
and William Fichtner is actually not
shredder what do we know about him in
the last trailer he was talking to April
O'Neil he was like we wanted to create
heroes your father and I that's what we
were
so he's a scientist and he's like I'm
gonna take your armor to the next level
so he's enhancing mechanically so
he's a smart guy and he's he baxter
stockman
i think he would be good as baxter
stockman what yes that's an awesome
baxter stockman if he's baxter stockman
are they gonna do a thing like GI Joe
where you have a ruku sake and Baxter
Stockman's like no I'm your humble
servant and then in the end he's like ha
I'm actually mecha shredder now it's
Baxter Stockman acting like the helper
but he has his plan again I don't know
but I was appointed trailer she do
theories and I don't know why they
had to make shredder mecha super robot
transformer shredder trailers looks like
one of those action figures that comes
out when the movie comes out and they
have those action figures that never
happened in the movie ever in this case
it's an exception because it was
actually in the movie that's what he
looks like he looks like a toy I do like
the part at the end where April O'Neil
and her news crew they were talking and
they were like so they're aliens and
April's like no that would be stupid
Oh Michael Vale you know they're they're
making fun of the old script and
that's that's neat to be honest the
action looks cool I like the concept
that maybe William Fichtner is not
shredder there is actually a naru
kesakhian he's actually shredder that
would be sweet I got like this trailer
made the movie look a lot better and it
made me go oh maybe I won't hate the
movie I'm open to those possibilities
I'm not have to just on the movie I
want to like movie I want to like every
movie I go into for the most part there
are exceptions to every rule but I do
want to like movies generally speaking
so the new Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here
see more